où est mon bébé vous avez fait perdre
son temps au FBI
celle de nos agents étaient tués
maintenant les conditions c'est nous qui
les imposons
adrianovel et Hector Alvarez sont en
liberté on sait toutes les deux que ce
que vous pouvez faire de mieux pour
protéger cet enfant c'est disparaître
et
vous retrouveront toutes les deux
ça y est vous repartez vous la mettez
chez des gens bien vous assurer sa
sécurité
si elle a des ennuis vous me prévenez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le secret est éventé
[Musique]
il se servent d'elle pour m'atteindre
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire je dois
assurer sa protection qui êtes-vous
quand tu es avec moi tu fais ce que je
te dis
tu conduis j'ai que 12 ans on y va
rentrer chez moi pas avant que je t'ai
appris la survie sous toutes ses formes
tu me fais peur à chaque fois que je te
vois j'ai peur regarde le bazar que tu
as mis
tu t'en iras pas cette fois
tu as mis en pièce tout ce qu'on avait
construit pour elle
et je suis aussi une mère
[Applaudissements]
et je donnerai ma vie
[Musique]